president biden at the white house this
afternoon defending his decision and
decisions
in the withdrawal of afghanistan let's
bring in former u.s ambassador to the
united nations nikki haley madam
ambassador thanks for joining us
your reaction to the president's speech
this afternoon
it was pretty clear that by the end of
that speech that president biden gave it
was the beginning of the lame duck
presidency for
joe biden i mean he has lost the trust
and confidence of every member of the
military and the military families that
i'm proud to be a part of he's lost the
trust and confidence of our allies who
are now negotiating without us because
they don't know why we're doing what
we're doing he's lost the trust and
confidence of the american people and i
think if you look at the fact that
they're
the jihadists are celebrating in the
streets because
um america was run out of town and by
the way they left them with billions of
dollars worth of equipment and
ammunition as a housewarming present i
mean you couldn't ask for a more
embarrassing humiliating situation than
what we have right now the world is
definitely a more dangerous place just
because we're out of afghanistan does
not mean this war is over
understanding that you would do things
differently and you have a lot of
criticism about where we are at this
point i'd like you to put on your
advisor hat if you are advising this
president let's say your secretary of
state or let's say your vice president
nikki haley
what do you tell this president now
today going forward not looking
backwards about what what to do with the
current situation
i would say stop talking about president
trump
start owning up to what has happened and
the first thing you should do is
immediately start connecting with our
allies
whether it's taiwan whether it's ukraine
whether it's israel whether it's india
australia japan all of them and reassure
them that we will have their back and
that we need them as well secondly we
need to make sure that we are going on
an anti-terrorist effort across the
world because we are now going to see
with this
moral victory that the jihadists have
you're going to see a heavy recruitment
campaign around the world you're going
to see more lone wolf situations we need
to make sure we're protected we need to
make sure our cyber security is strong
because
actors like russia are going to continue
to hack us because we show no signs of
willing to fight back we need to watch
china because i think you're going to
see china make a move for bagram air
force base and i think they're also
making a move in afghanistan and trying
to use pakistan to get stronger to go
against india so we've got a lot of
issues the biggest thing he should do is
strengthen our allies strengthen those
relationships modernize our military and
make sure we're prepared for the cyber
crimes and the terrorist crimes that are
headed our way yeah it's a big job
handling all of that but another thing
that has just popped up again is north
korea and the restarting of the nuclear
reactor at yongbyon you dealt with north
korea as the ambassador to the united
nations uh president trump obviously had
a very different
perspective when it came to that
your thoughts on this development
you know we led the charge on three
different sanctions packages against
north korea that totally neutralized
them what you're seeing kim do now is
basically he senses the weakness of
biden and so he's going to go ahead and
start getting aggressive his hope is
that he's going to get the united
nations to shake he's going to get other
countries around the world to shake to
lift sanctions to start sending them
money it's the last thing we should do
we should not do that the next thing
biden needs to do is to stand firm on
those sanctions he needs to make sure he
doesn't acknowledge the taliban as a
credible government he needs to also
make sure that he's strong and stays out
of the iran deal these are all going to
be very important issues that he has to
face going forward and he can't show any
weakness whatsoever you know we just had
this ceremony the trend the
bringing the bodies back
at dover
air force base in delaware and the
president and the first lady went as
well as the secretary of defense
and met with the families there as those
bodies were coming in the ultimate pain
would be to lose a son or daughter and
have to bury
your son or daughter and you can feel
that pain when they talk about it but i
was surprised by
how they characterized president biden
who's known for his empathy at least in
the past
of dealing with this moment let's take a
listen
we didn't want to deal with him we
didn't want to we didn't want him
anywhere near us it didn't go well
he talked a bit more about his own son
than we did my son and that that didn't
sit well with me he would not look us in
the eye there was not a
ounce of sympathy looking at his face it
was his his son and about him and
nothing to do with the 13.
first of all are you surprised about
that and second of all you've dealt with
families who've lost in 2015 and the
mother emanuel church when you're
governor of south carolina
what did you do there
i mean it's heartbreaking and i'll tell
you it's even closer to home than that
i'm the wife of a combat veteran who
deployed to afghanistan um we held our
breath the entire time they were gone
because we were scared that that that we
were going to have a knock on our door
and i hurt for those 13 families that
got a knock on their door and i heard
even more that they met with a president
that was completely tone deaf you don't
talk about the death of your own son
when you're talking about loss of life
of a military service man or woman this
is something that is the whole military
family feels this we're bonded by this
we're heartbroken by this and the one
thing you do is you sympathize with them
you hold them you hug them you let them
know that the greatness of their family
member and how the country is better for
them but i get why he didn't look them
in the face how could he look them in
the face when he knew he was the reason
that they died how could he look them in
the face when he knew that they didn't
close that gate and protect those
soldiers how does he look those families
in the face when those poor service men
and women who were doing their job had
to rely on the taliban a jihadist group
for protection that's why he couldn't
look him in the face that's why all he
could do was talk about beau was because
this is wrong on every level and we need
to wrap our arms around those military
families they didn't deserve this and
those men and women are heroes and
they'll be heroes for life
former ambassador to the united nations
nikki haley madam ambassador we
appreciate your time hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else